alright welcome everybody this is the
first of a series of kickoff events
leading towards the YC I annual
conference it's going to take place on
april nine to the yale school of law and
it's a conference you have to register
for so please do to do so and you can
link that webpage under wwl i'ma ldd you
we're having two more events coming up
the second one taking place on march
23rd at this very place and we're going
to have three engineering and science
students battling out battling out the
best technology to solve the energy
challenges that we're facing so they're
going to talk about battery technologies
about solar fuels and then also about
genomics and biofuels and then on March
30 years we're going to have professors
yell professors to talk about similar
topics and that's all going to be
announced on the web page of the YC I
today though I like to introduce dr.
Rajendra Pachauri he obviously doesn't
need much of an introduction I'd like to
have that some of his position
achievements however dr. Pachauri is the
chief executive of teri the energy and
research institute and he's also the
chairman of the IPCC and in that
position he won a nobel peace prize in
2007 together with Al Gore dr. Pachauri
has an associated with many research
institutes and academic institutes
including Yale University and he first
came to yell actually in 2000 as a
McCluskey fellow teaching at the school
of Forestry and environmental studies
and he returned so in 2009 he joined the
Yale Club and Energy Institute as a
director and the YC I is a faculty
initiative supported by president 11 to
put Yale on the map
of climate and energy research and
policy and last year we held the YC I
held its inaugural conference and this
year's conference is coming up as I
mentioned very soon and its title is
technology technological innovation for
an energy secure future so now without
further ado I'd like to give the stage
to dr. rajendra pachauri thank you thank
you ya know I was shaking your hand well
thank you very much for this opportunity
and I want to say that we place a great
deal of importance on this conference
because this is going to be an annual
event which would not only provide an
opportunity for the rest of the world to
get to know what the Yale climate and
energy institute is but for us to be
able to make a contribution in terms of
providing some directions some
perspectives and some priorities on what
needs to be done I need hardly mention
that the whole area of energy and
climate is something that's in an
extremely dynamic and and a critical
stage because obviously what has worked
in the past is not going to work in the
future but it's important for us to see
which directions we might move in to be
able to ensure that the 7 billion people
on this planet are able to live in a
situation of security in a situation
where they're very basic needs can be
met and how you define basic needs is in
itself a great challenge let me go back
historically to something which in
retrospect now seems like a failure on
the part of
analysts and those dealing with the
economic policy to identify something
that's really of crucial importance not
only to today's economic growth and
development but what would happen in the
future and to economic welfare and
progress as a whole if you look at what
economics to talk to you about growth
and development I wonder if that's my
telephone that we switch it off and put
it away in my pocket yeah I think the
main emphasis in economic models of
growth and development has been on
looking at capital and labor as the two
major inputs and the very theme of this
conference is something that was not
thought of explicitly because we
excluded technology and we excluded
energy growth was seen to be driven
essentially by these two sets of inputs
capital and labor and the models that
were developed to quantify this
relationship looked at output as a
function of the inputs of capital as
well as labor now this incidentally
changed substantially particularly after
after the first oil price shock of
1973-74 and the subsequent one the
second one in 1979-80 I think suddenly
the world woke up and the economics
profession woke up to see that clearly
there was an extremely important element
of inputs that are essential to bringing
about growth and development and which
they had neglected in the past now up to
that stage technology certainly had come
to be
regarded as an important driver of
growth and development and there are
several people who actually there was
Denison who went into quantification of
the contribution of technology to growth
and development by looking at the
contributions of capital and labour and
treating the residual as something that
must have come from technological change
and several other researchers did the
same thing I'm mentioning this only
because if one looks at tradition energy
and technology have really not been
given the explicit place that they
deserve in understanding what
contributes to economic output now
that's one issue that I think we need to
understand the second issue that we need
to understand is the need to see how
security is linked with the availability
and supply of energy because today's
economic engine is entirely dependent on
fossil fuels and we know that over a
period of time at least one form of
fossil fuels that's oil in particular is
getting increasingly dependent on
supplies from a very limited region of
the world and that raises issues of
supply I mean we know what's happening
today with all the trouble that's taking
place in Libya for instance there's been
a sudden impact on global oil prices and
where this will end one doesn't know
because if you're going to depend on a
small region which is going to supply
the bulk and certainly the increasing
share of oil in the future then
geopolitical factors become an extremely
important determinant of the security of
supply on a global level but there's
also another important area that we
not focused on in the past and that is
the whole issue of energy scarcity there
are a large number of people on this
globe today in the year 2011 who have no
access to what we regard as modern fuels
modern forms of energy and what we take
completely for granted there's anywhere
a number close to a billion and a half
people 1.5 billion people it could be
1.4 to 1.6 who have no access to
electricity and well over two billion
people are dependent for cooking at
least and for creating heat for a
variety of purposes for their well being
and existence on biomass resources and
with the scarcity of biomass increasing
the kind of fuels that they are using
today are becoming progressive
progressively inferior so therefore
there's a large share of the human
population today that clearly does not
have proper or reliable supply of energy
and I think the security of supply for
that section of the human race is also
an extremely important issue that we
have not dealt with so far now to
compound this situation and the
uncertainties that we see in the supply
of oil in particular and the price of
oil that would be ruling trade in the
future we really need to see what are
the major drivers by which energy
decisions are going to be taking taking
place firstly of course we know that as
far as oil supply is concerned we have a
cartel of sorts opec although I have
analyzed this in
considerable detail and I came to the
conclusion that OPEC is not really a
cartel a cartel is something we're
generally suppliers have an equal amount
of power but this is what in economics
is regarded as a dominant firm supply
system and here the dominant firm is
Lily really Saudi Arabia because Saudi
Arabia is the largest supplier of oil
and if you reading that you've been
reading the newspapers you would have
noticed that in view of the decline in
production in Libya Saudi Arabia has
already committed that is going to
increase and enhance its supply of oil
because they still have a certain amount
of surplus capacity which they can turn
on whenever the need arises whenever
they feel that prices need to be
moderated or supplies have to be
increased so it's in a sense not
strictly a cartel but it's a grouping of
suppliers where you've got one dominant
supplier and that's Saudi Arabia and
therefore to a large extent the
decisions that are taken in OPEC are the
result of positions taken by Saudi
Arabia not entirely but to a large
extent so if we look at the future of
energy supply then how OPEC is going to
behave is going to be an extremely
important driver what is even more
important is the manner in which demand
is going to continue to grow there are
two sides of the oil market and for the
moment I'm only focusing on the oil
market there is a supply side where
today we know that there really hasn't
been a major accretion of reserves by
which we can be assured that whatever is
the increase in demand supply will
respond to be able to provide the
quantities that are demanded but there
is of course the demand side and there I
think we have got into a structure
reality where by the manner in which we
use oil and energy general is
essentially dependent on technologies
that we have developed I mean one single
technology which i think is very
important for the supply of liquid fuels
of oil is the technology of the motor
vehicle now we are so dependent on this
we are so used to the use of this
particular technology that to shift away
from it is going to be extremely
difficult then we also know there's a
whole range of other uses and uses where
we are essentially dictated by
technologies and infrastructure that
cannot be changed overnight and this is
what brings about some degree of
uncertainty and therefore questioning of
the security of supply in the future but
if we want to ensure that there is a
smooth and affordable supply of energy
in the future then we will have to make
interventions on both sides those
interventions will have to be on the
demand side and if you look at oil as a
source of energy then clearly
transportation is the one sector which
is highly dependent on the use of oil
because the infrastructure that we have
created including roads highways the
entire automobile industry is such that
we cannot change it overnight we can
bring about incremental changes and
those incremental changes will have to
come about rather rapidly but we really
cannot bring about a wholesale change
over to something new a new set of
infrastructure so this to my mind is
something that policymakers have to take
into account but we must also accept the
fact that any effort to change
no matter how rational and desirable it
might be is going to be resisted by
those who see a decline in their own
business opportunities and this
certainly includes the automobile
industry it includes the highway
industry it includes the fossil fuel
industry and I'm not too sure whether
democracy gives us the elbow room by
which we can bring about the changes
rapidly enough and therefore
unfortunately it may be a very
unfortunate it may be something that is
not something that one would advocate
but there may have to be some
disruptions by which we are jolted into
taking decisions that might be to the
long long term benefit of humanity and
such a jolt could easily come from an
increase in oil prices to say a hundred
and fifty dollars a barrel it could also
come from some geopolitical problem as a
result of which physical supplies of oil
could be limited but overall I think
what we really need to do is to bring
about a clear projection of where we are
going and then identify interventions by
which we can bring about a shift to a
much more secure future and to bring
this about we would necessarily need
technologies and therefore research and
development strategies by which new
technologies can be developed or the
existing ones be improved but more than
that we would also need to restructure
some of our institutions by which
decisions are taken in the right
direction and I'll say a little more on
that in a while but to
obligate all of this is also the reality
of climate change we realize across the
globe that we have to now reduce the
emissions of greenhouse gases and the
bulk of these emissions come from the
burning of fossil fuels therefore we
would need technologies by which we can
bring about a shift to other sources of
energy away from dependence on fossil
fuels we will also need to invest in
research and development whereby we can
create viable economically economically
viable solutions to give us the reality
of supply from some of these alternative
sources and most importantly we need
efforts including research and
development for ensuring much more
efficient use of energy even when it
comes to the use of fossil fuels now in
the case of climate change in 1992 the
UN Framework Convention on Climate
Change came into existence and it was
intended that as part of this framework
convention and it was deliberately
called a framework convention because it
was not really in the nature of an
agreement that bound different countries
or different societies to certain
actions but it was an misses that under
this framework an agreement would be
developed under which most countries of
the world will have to be committed to
reducing the emissions of greenhouse
gases so that's how the Kyoto Protocol
came into existence which was in 1997
but the requirements for this protocol
to become internationally legal certain
number of countries had to ratify the
the protocol this included the United
States it included Australia and both of
these countries refused to ratify the
protocol so then it fell on Russia as
the last country to ratified because the
requirement was that it must be a
certain number of countries and they
must account for a certain percentage of
the overall global emissions of
greenhouse gases and it was Russia which
basically filled the gap to meet these
conditions and Russia decided to ratify
this in two thousand four and six months
later the Kyoto Protocol came into legal
existence but what is even worse quite
apart from this enormous delay in
getting an agreement in place is the
fact that even those countries which
have ratified the protocol have not
really stuck by its prevalence by its
provisions and they have not met the
commitments which they had signed on to
so therefore the effort thus far has
been very feeble and there is now an
ongoing set of negotiations by which it
is expected that a new set of
commitments will come into existence
after 2012 which is the first commitment
period of the Kyoto Protocol and these
negotiations have really not gone all
that well because it was intended that
the conference of the parties in 2009
which took place in Copenhagen would be
the point at which the world would come
to an agreement which would be binding
and by by which we would start reducing
emissions of greenhouse gases on a
programmed and committed basis that
didn't happen the cancun Conference of
the parties which took place just a
couple of months ago certainly provided
three months ago provided some hope
because
some fairly concrete directions have
been set and all of this translates into
actions by which energy use will have to
change and it'll have to move away from
the use of fossil fuels so where we are
at this point of time is not very
certain because much depends on the
following conference of the parties the
next one will take place in Durban and
whether we would be in a position to
arrive at an agreement by which
emissions of greenhouse gases and carbon
dioxide in particular can be reduced so
I wanted to highlight the fact that
we're at the juncture of uncertainty at
this point of time and therefore it is
particularly important for us to get
together some of the best minds those
from the field of science technology
policy making because each one of these
will have to mesh together to give us an
energy future that is secure and there
is a role for each of these elements to
play on an urgent and meaningful basis
now if we don't have proper policies
such as placing a price on carbon
there's really no incentive for
producers as well as consumers of energy
to move towards low carbon fuels and low
carbon products that would bring about a
reduction in emissions if science is not
going to deliver solutions which are
really out of the box and that can
become game changes then obviously there
is very little hope of bringing about a
radical shift in the structure of supply
of energy and the consumption in various
sectors of the economy and technology
the the engineering disciplines have an
extremely important role to play because
they have to translate scientific
discoveries scientific promise into tech
logical reality and this conference in
my view is coming at a stage when as you
know the kind of motivation for acting
to deal with the challenge of climate
change at least in this country is at a
low and if we can come up with solutions
then and disseminate them effectively
then we hope we can influence society in
this country and elsewhere now before I
stop I wanted to highlight another
aspect of the solutions that we must be
dealing with to reduce emissions of
greenhouse gases we certainly have to
devise policies by which we provide
incentives as well as dissented
disincentives to all the players hidden
in any society but we must also remember
that the future of energy supply has in
the end to become much more secure so
there's going to be a transition it's
not something which requires as the
throw of a switch to bring about the
shift and I think at every stage of the
plan that we developed for the future we
will have to see how lifestyle changes
how the induction of new technology how
scientific research and development
might make a contribution by which we
move to a desired end point and one
important reason why I think we need to
look at this entire scenario with the
sense of urgency is because there are
huge benefits from reducing emissions of
greenhouse gases those being a much more
secure energy future and also reducing
the level of air pollution at the local
level because air pollution
both indoor and outdoor is a major
killer in several parts of the world one
important area that unfortunately never
gets global attention is what I referred
to earlier the problem of energy
security for some of the poorest people
in the world now when they burn poor
quality fossil fuels of poor quality
biomass then there's a huge amount of
pollution that takes place and often
this is in a confined space because
people who burn these biomass fuels are
living in homes that are really very
meager they are very poor ventilation in
several cases so women and children in
particular taken large quantities of
noxious fumes and this leads to very
widespread upper respiratory diseases
which create morbidity of course but
also a large level of mortality so to
move to an energy secure future for this
section of society is also attendant on
improvements in health as a result of
lowering of air pollution another great
benefit of reducing emissions of
greenhouse gases and finding green
solutions secure solutions for energy
supply is the fact that agricultural
productivity would be much higher
climate change is already showing
impacts on agricultural yields which are
largely unfavorable and finally if you
go back to the whole understanding of
the economic structure of society today
then in several respects we have reached
a kind of a plateau if you look at the
developed countries much of the
manufacturing has moved to other parts
of the world and therefore if you have
to restart the engine of growth you
really don't have too many sectors where
you can bring about a major improve
of an increase in improvement and
increase in economic activity now one
means by which we can bring about a
regeneration of employment and therefore
economic welfare would be to create
these new sectors of energy supply
creating energy efficiency because all
of this will generate per per unit a
much higher level of employment then if
we would who can continue on it on the
conventional path so for all these
reasons I think it's critically
important for us to look at
technological solutions and see how a
coalition of different stakeholders can
bring about a major shift in
technological innovation and its use so
that we can create a much more secure
energy future so what I have said is
really general I've just tried to give
you an overview of the global problem of
energy security or the lack of it and
overview of the opportunities that we
are faced with and also the fact that
there is need for us to bring about some
rapid changes and if they don't seize
the moment then clearly the impacts of
climate change are going to be rather
disastrous not only for generations to
come but even for the generation that's
living on this planet today so I'll be
very happy to answer any questions and
any specific points that you wish to be
clarified i'll try to the bed to do the
best i can thank
thank you very much dr. Pachauri for
this some introduction to the conference
topic so as he said you would like to
take some questions um I have the mic
here give it over thank you again um so
within the u.s. there's been failure to
move forward with any sort of economic
signal any sort of price signal it looks
like it might be a few years before that
opportunity presents itself again there
are there are folks who were focusing
just on the need to facilitate
innovation what do you see as a path
forward within the u.s. that can get us
where we need to go quickly enough if a
price signal in any form is not an
option at least in the near term you
know if I was a policy maker I would
would make the argument of energy
security and I think this is something
that would go down well with the
population over here because you know
it's not all that long ago that you had
the two oil price shocks and today with
the situation that you have in Libya in
other countries and God knows what will
happen next people would be concerned
about this huge dependence on oil
imports as far as this country is
concerned the world today produces
little in excess of 80 million barrels
of oil a day and almost 20 million
barrels a day are being consumed in this
country so anything that happens to the
global oil market has a
disproportionately large impact on this
country largely because this is a
disparate disproportionately large
consumer of oil so I I would make the
argument that we have to move to a more
secure energy future and therefore to
bring that about these are the actions
that people have to take and that would
include certainly investments in public
transport and I know that's not going to
be easy politically it would certainly
include tighter
standards on efficiency of fuels in
automobiles perhaps regulation of energy
use and buildings which incidentally
pays for itself hands down because it's
an extremely attractive area for
bringing about technological
interventions both for new buildings
where the the scope is enormous but also
for for retrofits so I think these are
some of the arguments and messages that
leaders in this country must start
putting out you take the example of
California which has been ahead of
everybody else when it comes to a
sustainable energy future of course one
reason I was told is that California has
not a major producer of energy and
therefore it's been politically easy to
do that but not every state in this
country is an energy producer so let's
at least start with the states where
there is no vested interest in the form
of supply industry for energy so I think
we need to shift the focus of the
message and hopefully that will bring
about change
and
other than the obvious argument that
easier to in a place like like China or
something like that uh what what could
you flesh that out a little bit and
maybe what's the solution if that's the
problem no I didn't mean that there's a
flaw in democratic institutions I was
thinking of you know like the role and
the powers of an organization like the
EPA now the EPA certainly has the
mandate to reduce or at least require
reduction in emissions of greenhouse
gases but from the interaction that
we've had with them they're not really
well prepared and I think we need to
link them with institutions like this
and other systems whereby they get
inputs I feel they should also be far
more proactive in spreading information
to the public I mean the EPA is regarded
as a kind of if I can be candid as a
kind of an evil threat to society
because they're going to curb people's
rights to do what they should be allowed
to do but as I mentioned a little
earlier in spreading the message about
energy security and how to ensure it I
think organizations like the EPA can
play an extremely important role they
must have a public information program
so that people realize that this
organization is really doing something
for our good and the good of our
children and grandchildren the other
thing that I believe is required is to
create a platform where industry
government civil society academia can
come together because this is a problem
that's not going to be solved by any
single set of actors
we need all stakeholders to get involved
and the spa industry has really been
sulking in this area they haven't really
shown the kind of enthusiasm to solve
not just a national problem but an
international problem of huge dimensions
so we need to create some of these
institutions and I just wonder if the
president can set up a platform where
these things are debated and discussed
and we should sort of enliven the
discussion that is taking place at the
moment you get voices coming out of the
darkness attacking one or the other
element of what is being proposed I
think you need a much more open and a
much more vigorous and a better informed
debate I don't see a platform at this
point of time with that is happening
thank you very much dr. chewy um or no
IPCC is working on the fifth assessment
report I wonder if you can comment on I
guess what's the progress of it and what
do you think will be a big difference
from the fourth one thank you well we
are in the early stages of preparing the
fifth assessment report we've had two
sets of lead author meetings you know
there are three working groups two of
them have kicked off their work the
third one will be doing that very soon
but in addition to the fifth assessment
report we also bringing out two special
reports in May we complete a special
report on renewable energy and in
November of this year we'll have a
report on extreme events where people
will hopefully be able to understand the
link between climate change and the
occurrences frequency intensity of
extreme events so as far as the fifth
assessment report is concerned we
certainly will have much more knowledge
because in the past few years there's
been much more research and therefore
substantial increase in public
patient's activity now that also
increases the burden on the authors who
are going to write the report because
just to give you a number in the fourth
assessment important there were roughly
18,000 published sources of material
that we had to that we had to study and
assess this time around it could be
three to three times that number so i
mean i'm glad i'm not an author anyway i
got a lot of flak for being chairman of
the IPCC but being an author would only
add a little more to that because you'd
have to study a lot you and you'll have
to be very careful in interpreting all
the material that you study it's it's a
pre daunting task however I think with
this increase in knowledge which is
taking place I imagine we'll be able to
sort of bridge some of the gaps that
exist currently we are also looking at
some new subjects we certainly going to
provide much greater regional detail on
the impacts of climate change and I hope
you succeed in doing that we're going to
look at the role of aerosols and and
cloud cover in understanding how much of
a role they play in bringing about
climate change we're going to look at
ethics eight equity issues and there
will be a much greater emphasis on some
of the economic and socio-political
aspects of what needs to be done so
there are quite a few new topics that we
have included not that these were not
there earlier but since we have
identified them explicitly and we are
going to place much greater emphasis on
them I expect we'll have a lot more
information this time around on some of
these subjects
it was two more questions here but i'm
just going to abuse my power right now
and ask a question myself picking up on
the research topic we're always i'm
talking about technology technological
innovation and like these major
breakthroughs being a scientist at a
accredited university here I'm very much
aware about like the costs of research
and how much it takes to come forward
with great ideas and follow them through
so I would be interested what would you
take is on where funding money for for
those ideas and technologies will be
coming from and and how we can increase
these funds yeah I think that's a very
good question I I would see funding
being stepped up or I'd like to see it
being stepped up in two areas one is on
the pure science itself we're clearly
the certainty associated with reaching
any level of success is not very high
now that's an area where government has
to provide funding and we know from past
experience wherever governments have
taken a lot of initiative and have shown
some vision in providing adequate
funding the benefits to society opinion
norms you take the case of the space
program at the time when President
Kennedy said that we line the person on
the boon everybody thought that this is
only satisfaction of national ego but it
just led to the development of a new
industry a new area of knowledge which
has had so many spillover effects I mean
as a result of space technology you know
now where your water resources are you
can carry out a mapping of so many
extremely important pieces of
information that have transformed our
lives and we have taken them for granted
and I imagine in this entire space of
energy environment climate change
governments have the primary role for
funding the scientific aspects of
research now if you look at the
technology part then this is where yes
governments can come in to some extent
but i think the bulk of the effort and
funding has to come from industry but
here again government has a role because
government must provide the right
signals I mean for instance I'm not
saying that we get rid of the motor cars
that are being produced today but
government can clearly lay down a road
map to say okay if efficiency and fuel
standards are X at this point of time in
the next five years they must rise to 2x
and the years after that next ten years
they must rise to sue and so otherwise
there will be certain penalties that I
imposed now that would induce an inner
in a sense that's providing a price on
carbon and that would induce industry to
move in a particular direction so here
again where we expect industry to
provide most of the funding to bring
about technological change there is
clearly a role for government and
society at large so I think this is
where we somehow need to create the
platform that I was talking about and I
hope a conference like ours would be a
useful starting point to look at some of
these elements of what policy should be
what industry should be looking at
because often industry has a very
short-term myopic view of benefits in
terms of profits and profitability they
have to start looking beyond because
we're living in a globalized world and
everybody in the future is going to move
to a low-carbon economy and those
industries that don't wake up to that
fact are the ones who are going to be
left
behind so we have to somehow induce that
kind of thinking in the leadership of
industry some of them are already doing
it but there's a large number that need
to be sensitized to this reality I thank
you you mentioned the two billion people
that don't have access to adequate forms
of energy but in a country like India
the increase in emissions and
consumption is really driven by the
Durban izing middle portions of the
society classes so I was wondering if
you could comment on how that pattern
could be addressed in terms of you know
whether broader macro economic social
macro economic and social policy versus
technology and how we can address that
you know change that that particular
class maybe with respect to India in
particular well you know they're two
dimensions that we need to look at
certainly the urban problem where
unfortunately those who are rising to
the level of the upper middle class are
trying to emulate patterns that you have
in the developed world and that I
suppose is understandable because you
can't have two standards governing
behavior of human beings in different
parts of the globe but I think we have
to realize the benefits from a different
path of development as far as a country
like India is concerned we cannot
possibly consume resources on a per
capita basis as the developed world is
has been consuming simply because we'll
run out of those resources we won't be
able to afford them but then there's the
other problem of the rural areas and
here I was going to show you a three
minute film we need to ensure that
technological change touches the lives
of people who are completely out of this
system at this
time and it is with this in view that
we've launched this program called
lighting a million lives and I wonder if
this is the appropriate stage when I
could play the video I would know how to
do it
so so you basically need technology not
only in terms of coming up with
solutions that are cost-effective that
are technologically viable but also one
needs means by which you can spread
these innovations and I think given the
fact that as far as the poor people in
the world are concerned you're really
starting from scratch you therefore have
an opportunity to bring about change
which is really radical and I think
there's also a wealth of humanitarian
reasons why we need to focus on that
section of society the world and i would
say national governments have just not
focused on these underprivileged people
so far at least